I don't think people really see the fact
that people with disabilities have
sexual desires I have a sex swing that's
amazing I don't necessarily think that
it's a bad word and that it's something
we shouldn't use but I also don't think
it should be the only word that defines
us either I understand like disableds
like means not able to and like I feel
like I'm able to do most things I'm an
able person can do I just have to do
them differently I think it's a better
word than words that have been used to
describe me I hate the word special I I
think it's so demeaning and like I was
called it my childhood you know like
special ed I I literally get like chills
thinking about that word
and so then disabled I feel like is a
more mature version that doesn't hold
that connotation for me
health care from my point of view is not
made for people who have chronic
disabilities chronic diseases even if
you have medical coverage you're still
paying a portion of those bills it's a
cycle that you put yourself in debts
that you can't get a proper apartment or
get a house for the people who they
count it as SSI so it's low income
Social Security they think that you
should be able to live off of like $900
a month there's also a thing with it you
can't have more than two thousand
dollars in your account for checking and
savings and as soon as you hit a cent
over it you lose your Social Security
because they think you're making too
much so I have a chronic illness called
idiopathic hypersomnia which is the
sleep disorder from the onset of
symptoms it took eight years to even get
sent to a sleep doctor and not to
mention the education system I'm so
lucky that I have an IEP I couldn't
imagine what school would be like if I
didn't but even with that getting the
accommodations of like my teachers
trying to understand that I only come to
school three out of five days a week and
that I can't do busy work because I'll
fall asleep quite literally I legally
have these rights to not do certain work
and sometimes teachers just don't
understand that and it's so hard trying
to argue with them so that I can just be
a normal student
a lot of people have been so
understanding and accommodating and like
Oh like you know I heard about that from
this TV show or like is it like this or
like you know asking questions and I
think people are genuinely curious there
are people that I educate and are still
ignorant and totally Meany pants that's
why I'm not and strongly disagree
because there's always gonna be haters
you know but I think people are good so
for me I would agree but I would come
from like a place of understanding
because I feel like even people with
disabilities don't understand other
people with disabilities as well because
I feel like you know you could have the
same kind of disability the same type
but the way it affects you could be very
different I have a disease called
muscular dystrophy and that is a wide
spectrum and so you can't really
understand it because some people their
muscles get weaker quicker than others
I have spina bifida and the type I have
is lipo myelomeningocele my dad served
in the Vietnam War
and a chemical called Agent Orange he
came in contact with and that chemical
caused my spina bifida when you learn
about spina bifida most people think
that their wheelchair users and it's
also because the spina bifida
Association they only show one narrative
of it which is an issue in general
across the disability spectrum I have a
channel where I educate about disability
as a whole and even people who are
trying to learn still want to argue with
a disabled person when we're teaching
them
I use a cane on and off when I do have
my cane I like that people offer me help
when I'm writing the metro or the bus
but then it's the extra comment that
they think they're doing like a great
deed that they're gonna win a Nobel
Peace Prize and they'll start
infantilizing me oh you're so cute and
tiny and you're too young to be sick I
just don't like the extra comments with
the help so I moved because I think I
have a little bit of a different
experience I am a hundred percent
physically able so I don't have the need
for people to open doors for me like I
don't need help like that sometimes I
have to cancel events and my friend like
my good friends understand that and I
feel like there's a difference between
accommodation and patronizing I remember
before I had my accident I probably was
one of those people that we were talking
about when someone is overly
enthusiastic about it or even sometimes
unintentionally patronizing I try in my
experiences to instead educate them that
I know I'm gonna chair and I know that I
look like I have a lot of issues but
trust me I've been out here thuggin it
out for a while now if I need help I'm
not ashamed to ask for it I've had
strangers like come up behind me and
just start pushing me even though I
don't necessarily need a help with that
if you're somebody that I know and you
see that I'm struggling then you can go
ahead and probably help me wiill but if
you don't know me at all
please don't come up behind me and start
trying to push me out of nowhere it also
puts us at risk of injury I have nerve
damage of my feet so I look down a lot
when I walk because it helps me keep my
balance and then I've had people see
that I'm like trying to get through and
they'll grab my arm to guide me and I
almost always fall because I'm already
so in my zone
so like just don't touch people because
you could injure them so for me it's
difficult on various levels I started
having seizures when I was 18 I became
sick when I was about 16 so I never got
a license I never got a car so that
impairs my ability to even go find
suitors because I don't get out of my
house much and then being on Social
Security you get paid
hardly anything so I can't even afford
to really go out and do a whole lot and
then on top of that trying to explain to
a man that oh yeah you know just to let
you know I'm a full package it's going
to have a huge effect on our
relationship on our ability to go out on
our sex life on everything I came over
here because after listening to you
there's so many things that I totally
resonate with but then there's so many
odd benefits that I think that comes
with dating and having a disability I
got injured after gymnastics accident
when I was 14 years old that left me
quadriplegic I never got to experience
being you know a teenager being wild
dating and all of those things the
people who have been in my life we
really had to get to know each other on
a deeper level first before any other
physical aspects were part of it anybody
disabled or able-bodied all we want is
someone who truly loves us for us and
this is me I'm right here because dating
is not really in in my focus right now
but I could see how hard it could be
because you know I may not be able to
live long but then at the same time I
think it could also be a good thing
because I think true love is when you
really understand each other I
kind of agree with that if I'm looking
at my most recent relationship my
partner he was really great like he took
the time to understand my disability
what made it difficult at times was when
I was having a lot of kidney issues and
I wasn't getting the greatest news from
my doctors and so I would be sobbing and
he just had this need that he wanted to
help and I just told him like I don't
need anything physically from you I just
need to just sit with me ever since we
broke up and I've started getting back
out and dating I will get people that
will ghost me because of looking able
passing on like dating websites they
don't know right away
and I don't share it right away because
I'd rather have a person conversation
about it I also hate the invasive
questions that come with dating I've
been asked so many times can you even
have sex or the men who fetishize it oh
I've had a guy ask me to bring the cane
into the bedroom just insane ridiculous
things I've had guys literally say they
want to check it off on their bucket
list to sleep with a girl in a chair or
yeah the invasive questions that come
straight off the bat I don't think
people really see the fact that people
with disabilities have sexual desires I
have a sex swing that's amazing it's a
most accessible thing for me and it's
great
when it comes to my parents a lot of the
time because I'm paraplegic I was in a
car accident when I was 11 wheelchair
accessible vehicles are very very
expensive so it's my parents
or my brother that often have to take me
from place to place I know a lot of the
time they don't mind and my mind just
takes it to that place just because I'm
I can be a very pessimistic think you're
a lot of the time but I do a lot of the
time feel like a burden in that way I
already know it's probably gonna break
my mom's heart when she watches this but
before I could even figure out the words
felt like a burden to my parents because
they took out so many loans before the
VA finally agreed to cover me and they
didn't agree until I stopped having back
surgeries I still feel so degree I'm a
burden and I'm a result of why most of
my family's in poverty and part of that
is kind of the reason I moved all the
way to Los Angeles my family's on the
East Coast and I figured if I'm not near
them they can't take care of me so
they're free to live however they want
to live I've had friends who have just
left me because they didn't want to
accommodate and I try to work on that of
like no I'm not a burden but it's hard
sometimes yeah
I'm literally over here I know that I'm
a burden I would not be here without my
mom she's a single parent and she has
sacrificed everything for me
she has sacrificed her well-being
her mental health I don't think
I tell her often enough how much I
appreciate her but I've liked listening
to you I've lost friends because I was
too much of a burden and I was too much
of a hassle I always feel like a burden
but I can't stand on that line simply
because the people who love me would
hate that I feel this way because I know
that in their hearts I'm not a burden to
them but I would give anything to be
able to make my life not affect others
that I love negatively the way that has
because it's it's the guilt that we feel
with it because it's like I see my dad
is like a very stereotypical Puerto
Rican man he does not show emotions but
I can I remember when I'd be screaming
in the hospital him fighting back tears
because I know he blames himself because
of his military service and I feel just
guilty like if I didn't exist or if just
all like my parents were pregnant before
me and they lost that child if that baby
had stayed my dad wouldn't feel so much
pain about something he can't control
about my life and I hate that that I
can't make their lives easier
it's the feeling that it's out of
control how you're making others feel
because like usually you know if you're
nice that person is gonna feel good this
is something that we just are and like
it's hard enough to accept our selves
and like asking somebody else to accept
us is hard
[Music]
I'm right here because it has taught me
many life lessons and it has made me a
stronger person when I was younger I
would use to get stared at a lot and so
you know that would really affect me but
because I experienced that you know I
now have the strength to realize that
how others are looking at me doesn't
matter it's given me a lot of
opportunities to help people get out of
their dark times because if I never
experience depression you know I would
not be able to help people with
depression for me I don't have a before
being disabled the only thing I've ever
known the word itself comes with a lot
of community it comes with a history
that I'm so proud to be a part of that I
just I couldn't see myself living any
other way and like I know people will
say well there are more things about you
than just your disability and that's I
mean that's true for everyone there are
other things about me but everything I
do I do as a disabled person and for me
that's the most empowering thing I would
change maybe like I wish I could feel my
feet again that would be great but I
really wouldn't change much because it's
given me such a community that I don't
think I would have had even though I
know that I've had an impact on people
and I can relate to people in a way that
I probably couldn't have before I'm in
pain every second of every day I would
give almost anything to not have that
anymore I got sick young but I don't
remember what it's like not to be in
pain every day I wouldn't wish this on
anyone
I have lived both experiences and
similar to you I also am in pain almost
every single day if I were to be able to
take and swallow a pill tomorrow that
would make me better I would still be
able to take all
the lesson in experiences that I've been
able to garner from this accident and
continue to build coffin and do better
things but I think I would be really
lying to myself to say that I wouldn't
change it because I went from being
someone who literally was as athletic as
you could ever be flying high and doing
things with my body and I feel very
privileged to have live that and I know
what that feels like and I miss it every
single day not because like I don't love
my life or anything like that I can't
say I'm fulfilled until you know I
impact more people I'm working to be a
motivational speaker and so I have a lot
more to accomplish again going back to
the last question if I could change
everything of course but I think that my
life and my example is starting to help
people in many different facets and I
think part of being a good human is
trying to help as many people in your
life and I think I'm starting to do up
[Music]
hello good humans thank you for sticking
around to the end Aaron just want to ask
you what have you been learning kind of
in directing spectrum I think the
biggest thing for me is there have been
prompts or I assume everybody would just
agree or disagree on that completely to
only be surprised in the way that people
interpret the prompt kind of just sheds
light on some of the ignorance I have
her in sumption I have and I think
that's the beauty of this show bringing
an education and value for people who
are not a part of the community right
tell us what struck you about this
episode if you even have a personal
anecdote or story we love hearing that
and we love seeing this engagement in
the comments below make sure you follow
us on Instagram as well because that's
where we're getting a lot of our prompts
like subscribe and we'll see you next
time
thanks guys